welcome back I'm excited for this one
hot cocoa bombs are all the craze during
the holidays and the secret to them
tasting extra special is the quality of
the chocolate used in them so here to
show us how it's done right we have
Alicia Cerna and her daughter Annabelle
thank you so much for being here say hi
so good to see you guys thank you for
having us back of course thanks for
being here I all of these are so fun and
pretty they're almost too pretty to put
in the hot chocolate but everyone's like
yeah tell us about hot chocolate bombs
and how they work so it's pretty much
just hot hot cocoa but inside of a ball
of chocolate so it's a really fun way to
drop it inside of hot milk or you could
pour hot milk on top of them and it's
super fun for the kids and it's just
perfect for Christmas fun for the kids
and the adults you guys are going to
show us how it's done and this is really
fun because you can make these at home
and decorate them any way you want but
kind of run me through it here yeah so
it's really easy all you need is a
little silicone mold and you can pour
the chocolate inside let it Harden add
your hot cocoa mix marshmallows and then
it comes out as a ball you have to put
them glue them together and you can just
decorate so Annabelle's going to show us
how she likes to add her sprinkles are
you ready okay Annabelle Let's see how
it's done do you love hot chocolate
bombs Annabelle Okay add the sprinkles
we need the sprinkles okay so we Frost
it we add some sprinkles
the more the better I knew I liked
Annabelle the minute I met her and you
can roll it in there look how pretty
okay you want to drop it inside you want
to drop it in there so we can show how
it works I think we have a camera up top
there we go
so you can also pour the hot milk on top
and as you'll notice it'll start to open
and marshmallows will start fluffing up
and we have these cute little spoons
with chocolate and you can stir it
Annabelle likes to take control in the
kitchen I like her and as she's stirring
that up this is obviously fun for
Christmas holiday times but you also
have a glitter one yeah New Year's is
around the corner so a great way if
you're staying home with the kids you
can make a glitter ball here it's 100
edible it's shine dessert glitter that
I'm using and what you could do with the
kids is drop it in the bowl as your way
of doing like the ball drop yeah I knew
and the way to do it for the kids but
also for adults if you drop a little bit
of like Baileys inside of it it tastes
really good okay I knew I liked you too
that's really fun fun for the holidays I
didn't even know that you could have
edible glitter like yeah and it's so
sparkly and fun I was looking at your
social media earlier so much fun to
follow along where can people find you
to learn more tips um at love chocolate
dessert shop love chocolate dessert shop
you guys thank you so much for being
here Annabelle is a good
I think she's liking it can I have a
marshmallow all right and about having
one too oh a few you need more than one
thank you both so thank you for being
here and um to make your own hot
chocolate bombs oh no I dropped it all
right Stacy over to you I love it thank
you so much Julian it is the last week
to